Peter Drucker famously said if you want
if I want to know what you believe I
could ask you what you believe and maybe
I'll believe your answer but show me
your calendar and your bank statement
and then I'll really know what's going
on and what we tried to calculate was
the altered state economy how much time
and money do people spend trying to
change the channel on normal waking
consciousness and unlock these
heightened states of information we did
a global calculation we looked
everywhere from illicit to illicit drugs
which is an obvious place to start but
we also looked at things like
pornography and social media where the
neurochemical your reward you're getting
from these experiences is very similar
to the neurochemical reward you're
getting in these states at the heart of
a lot of this is the chemical dopamine
dopamine is a focusing drug as a
performance-enhancing drug and it's a
pleasure drug it is also incredibly
incredibly incredibly addictive porn
addiction is very much about dopamine
right if you think about porn from an
evolutionary point of view our sex drive
is about procreation we're not getting
any of that
from porn we're not watching porn for
what it makes us feel sexually we're
watching porn for what it does to us
mentally it changes our state of
consciousness it gets us high and it's
the dopamine that is getting us high it
is knocking out a side of normal waking
consciousness and it's lifting us up to
a heightened state unfortunately porn on
demand tends to be very very addictive
and people get in into a downstream
cycle with it we see the same thing with
social media right simon Sinek famously
says if you know you wake up in the
morning and you're you know checking
your phone before you're saying hello to
your spouse that's an addictive behavior
and it's dopamine that is driving that
addiction so what happens with social
media is Robert Sapolsky you did the
foundational research on this at
Stanford calls it the magic of maybe
when you look at your phone and maybe
there's a text there and maybe there's
not and you don't know when it shows up
that high you get that's dopamine it's
the
maybe maybe it'll be there maybe it
won't want it shows up you get a 400%
spike in dopamine that is roughly the
same amount of dopamine as you're
getting from cocaine it's slightly less
than an extremely addictive drug like
cocaine and that's what's happening and
it's interesting because if you think
about things like things that you know
routinely produce a lot of dopamine
alcohol for example there's a drinking
age right we have a drinking age the
alcohol releases a whole lot of dopamine
it makes you feel really really good we
say okay you can have that but you've
gotta wait you've got to be 21 years old
we don't do that with online pornography
you might want to do with online
pornography we don't do that with social
media we're you know essentially putting
highly addictive drugs into the hands of
kids before they have any natural
defenses against them and what you're
seeing with Internet addiction with
social media addiction with porn
addiction it's the same thing over and
over it's people trying to change their
state of consciousness with a device
trying to get at the underlying neural
chemical chemistry and it's very very
addictive
[Music]